we have now learned that the Trump White
House recently privately asked the FBI
to denounce news stories on the ties
between Russia and the Donald Trump team
and the FBI said no the White House
asked the FBI and other intelligence
agencies to publicly say there has been
no contact between White House staff and
Russia this would be a lie of course the
White House asked multiple intelligence
agencies to flat-out lie and aside from
being a request to lie the request
itself is a violation of Justice
Department rules which prohibit
communication with the FBI about and
related to pending investigations
there's a very clear rule about that a
White House official has now said that
Reince Priebus privately asked FBI
director James Comey for the FBI to
leaked info to reporters that the White
House doesn't have ties with Russia as
you probably have realized Comey and the
FBI didn't go along with that
immediately trumpets are calling this
fake news but of course what that means
is it's news that they don't agree with
but they don't like the White House
originally denied that they made the
request
but eventually they admitted that they
made the request when press secretary
Sean Spicer said quote we didn't try to
knock the story down we asked them to
tell the truth of course that wouldn't
be the truth since there are endless
connections between Trump and Russia
that have now been confirmed the FBI was
asked to comment about this situation
they didn't it's funny how all of a
sudden Pat the FBI doesn't comment it no
longer relates to Hillary Clinton's
emails weeks before the election so now
the FBI doesn't comment hey everybody
wake up
not only is there growing evidence that
Trump staffers have been in contact with
Russia now they're trying to corruptly
use law enforcement and intelligence
agencies to cover it up and still many
trump is safe nothing to see here
well it definitely is a double standard
here but I think it's just hilarious how
the Trump administration would think
that they'd be able to stop the FBI from
conducting this in a minute of this
investigation because they've been doing
this since the summer I'm sure there's a
ton of manpower and resources devoted to
this and yes they are part of the
executive branch but I mean you'd like
to think that the intelligence community
has
some independence from the president so
of course they're going to continue on
this investigation and who knows what
the results will be if there is a silver
lining it maybe is that the FBI didn't
appease them and rejected this request
maybe Comey and the FBI are taking into
account Trump's bad-mouthing of the FBI
and intelligence agencies and what Pat
is alluding to is right as I've said it
before it's abundantly clear that both
quote the media and intelligence
agencies have a lot of really damaging
stuff about Donald Trump it doesn't seem
like a pragmatically smart idea to go to
war with media and intelligence agencies
when they have a lot of information
there that could really end up screwing
you it may not it may not because we
have as I mentioned so many trumpets pot
committed as I called it to the Trump
regime but guys don't forget that Bill
Clinton met with Loretta Loretta Lynch
on an airport tarmac once during the
campaign that's the real scandal or
Hillary Clinton's emails or maybe
Benghazi if you're more of a nostalgic
individual who likes to go back to the
earlier scandals of the election send me
your thoughts about this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman we are on Twitter as a show
at david pakman show and we'll be back
right after this